grand theft auto 5 is being remade block  by block in Minecraft the project's name  is GTA 5 in Minecraft spearheaded by  team will aim to recreate every section  of the game from the city of Los Santos  to the mountains of Blaine County the  project is a massive undertaking the map  is estimated to be the size of 7,500 by  7,500 blocks the team started working on  the project since last year january 2015  and youtube user the nick has been  documenting its progress by releasing  walking videos on his youtube channel  subscribe to the next youtube channel  for his regular updates which even  includes a 360-degree video and of  course keep it at gamespot for your  daily gaming news